to put some terms on the table so we
understand them
um
you nonchalantly say it's always
the on average expanding every year the
money supply is expanding every year by
seven percent that's a bad thing that's
a that's a universally bad thing
it's awful
well i guess i guess to be precise
uh it's the currency
that i mean
my money uh i would say money is
monetary energy or economic energy
and the economic energy has to find its
way into a medium so if you want to move
it rapidly as a medium of exchange has
to find its way into currency but the
money can also flow into property
like a house or gold
if the money flows into property
it'll probably hold its value much
better if the money flows into currency
right if you had put a hundred thousand
dollars in this house
you would have 305x return over 92 years
but if you had put the money a hundred
thousand dollars in a safe deposit box
and buried it in the basement
you would have lost
99.7 percent of your wealth over the
same time period
so um so the expansion of the currency
creates uh creates a massive
inefficiency in the society what i'll
call an adiabatic lapse
it's
what we're doing is we're bleeding
the civilization to death right the
antibiotic adiabatic what's that word
that's
adiabatic adiabatic
right and aerospace engineering you want
to solve any problem they they start
with the phrase assume an adiabatic
system and what that means is a closed
system okay so i've got it i've got a
container and in that container no air
leaves and no air enters no energy exits
or enters so it's a closed system
so you got the closed system lapse
okay
okay i'm gonna use a there's a leak in
the ship i'm gonna use a physical
metaphor for you because you're the jiu
jitsu right like yeah like you got 10
pints of blood in your body
and so before your next uh workout i'm
going to take one pint from you
now you're going to go exercise but
you're one point you've lost 10 of your
blood
okay you're not going to perform as well
it takes about one month for your body
to replace the red blood platelets so
what if i tell you every month you got
to show up and i'm going to bleed you
yeah okay so uh so if i'm draining the
energy i'm drink i'm training the blood
from your body you can't perform
if you adiabatic lapse is when you go up
in altitude every thousand feet you lose
three degrees
you go 50 000 feet you're 150 degrees
colder than sea level that's why you you
know you look at your
instruments and instead of 80 degrees
you're minus 70 degrees why is the
temperature falling temperature's
falling because it's not a closed system
it's an open system as the air expands
the density falls
right the inner
the energy
per
uh
per cubic whatever you know falls and
therefore the temperature falls right
the heat's falling out of the solution
so
when you're inflating let's say you're
inflating the money so the currency
supply by six percent you're sucking six
percent of the energy
out of the fluid that the economy is
using to function so the currency this
kind of ocean of currency that's a nice
way for the economy to function it's the
most kind of uh
it's being inefficient when you expand
the money supply but it's uh
that look it's the liquid i'm trying to
find the right kind of adjective here
it's how you do transactions at a scale
of billions
currency is the asset we use
to move monetary energy around and you
could use the dollar or you could use
the peso or you could use the bolivar
selling houses and buying houses is much
more inefficient
or like uh
you can't
transact between billions of people with
houses yeah properties don't make such
good mediums of exchange they make
better stores of value and they they
have utility value if it's a if it's a
ship or a house or or a plane or a
bushel of corn
you